معنا من الكنيست من امام الكنيست في القدس
مراسل الجزيره الياس كرام الذي يتابعه عن
كثب كل هذه التطورات
اليوم بالفعل وبالامكان القول بان
المظاهرات امام مبنى الكنيسه الاسرائيلي
قد تجددت بالفعل ونحن امام هذا المشهد
الذي يشارك فيه الاف الاسرائيليين الذين
جاؤوا الى مبنى الكنيست هنا في القدس
الغربيه للتظاهر ومواصله هذه الاحتجاجات
الشعبيه على حكومه اقصى اليمين في اسرائيل
التي تسعى الى احداث هذه التغييرات
القانونيه والقضائيه ونحن بانتظار ان يخرج
رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو الى
الاسرائيليين في خطابه المنتظر والذي اجل
في الساعه الاخيره نظرا كما يبدو الى
خلافات داخل اعضاء الائتلاف الحاكم في
اسرائيل حول مساله وقف التشريعات القضائيه
والاحداث هذه التغييرات في الجهاز القضائي
حتى هذه الساعه بنيامين نتنياهو يحظى بدعم
كما يبدو من داخل حزب الليكود الحاكم ليس
الجميع في داخل حزب اللكود يؤيدون وقف هذه
التشريعات والتغييرات القضائيه لكن
بنيامين نتنياهو مدعوم الان من عدد من
كبار وزراء حزب النقود في حكومته وهم
يقولون بانهم سوف يوافقون على اي قرار واي
موقف يعلنه بنيامين نتنياهو في هذا الصدد
من يمين نتنياهو ايضا مدعوم من جانب احزاب
المتدينين في حكومته حركه شاص للمتدينين
الشرقيين وحركه يهدو تترا للمتدينين
الغربيين هاتان الحركتان اعلنتا ان
موقفهما سيكون موقفا مطابقا لما يعلنه
بنيامين نتنياهو بخصوص هذه التشريعات فيما
اذا كان سيوقفها ام سيتابع
تشريعها في الكنيست الاسرائيلي وطبعا
التقديرات تشير الى ان بنيامين نتنياهو
يميل الى وقف هذه التشريعات على ضوء هذه
الاحتجاجات الشعبيه الصاخبه والمتواصله
وغير المسبوقه في تاريخ اسرائيل يبقى الان
ما يجري في الجناح الاكثر تشددا والاكثر
تطرفا في الحكومه الاسرائيليه نتحدث عن
الصهيونيه الدينيه المتمثله بوزير الماليه
الذي اعلن معارضته لوقف هذه
التشريعات وهذه التغييرات في النظام
القضائي لكن البيان الذي اصدره الحزب لا
يحمل اي تهديد من جانبه لزعزعه اركان
الحكومه وزعزعه التوليفه الحاكمه في
اسرائيل تبدو المعضله الان هي وزير
الماليه لتمر بن جير الذي اشار او نقل عنه
قوله بان وقف هذه التشريعات من شانها ان
تزعزع اركان الحكومه الاسرائيليه واذا فقد
بنيامين نتنياهو اصوات هذا الحزب فهذا
يعني بان بانه ربما يفقد التوليف الحاكم
دعوني فقط اشير الى الاجراءات الامنيه
المشدده التي تفرضها القوات الاسرائيليه
حول مبنى الكنيست وهنالك مخاوف لديها من
ان المتظاهرين ربما يحاولون اجتياز
حواجزها ويدخلون الى البرلمان لذلك نحن
نرى بان قوات الشرطه الاسرائيليه وضعت
حواجز في عده حلقات حول مبنى الكنيست من
اجل وضع عراقيل وصعوبات امام المظاهرين
فيما اذا قرروا ان يجتازوا هذه الحواجز
ويدخل الى مبنى الكنيسه
الرافضه لهذه القرارات المتعلقه بالقرارات
القانونيه هناك دعوات ايضا لمظاهرات مؤيده
ماذا في تفاصيل هذه الدعوات
بالفعل هنالك دعوات من جانبي اليمين
المتطرف في اسرائيل وتحديدا ايضا من
تنظيمات متطرفه كتنظيم لافاميليا العنصري
المتطرف هؤلاء دعوا الى تظاهره مساء هذا
اليوم في وسط تل ابيب قباله التظاهرات
المناضه لهذه التغييرات القضائيه وهذا
بطبيعه الحال يخلق ازمه ربما لدى افراد
الشرطه الاسرائيليه التي ستضطر الى محاوله
وضع حواجز ما بين الطرفين المتصارعين في
هذه الحاله خشيه وقوع صدامات او مواجهات
بين الطرفين كما وقع في مرات
سابقه في احتكاكات لم تكن على مستوى كبير
صدامات كبيره لكنها كانت اشتباكات بالايدي
وهنالك خشيه على ضوئي هذه التطورات من ان
تشهد هذه التظاهرات المضاده ايضا يعني
عنفا من جانب الطرفين
المتظاهرين في هذه الحاله الشرطه
الاسرائيليه
تبذل جهدا كبيرا في وضع
المدنيس ووضع قواتي على لعبه الاستعداد
نحن نرى الان مبنى الحكومه حيث كان
الاجتماع ينعقد ما بين رئيس الوزراء
بنياميناهو وقاده
الاحزاب المضويه تحت حكومته هذا الاجتماع
انتهى كما اشرنا لم يعلن حتى هذه الساعه
الى ماذا توصل هذا الاجتماع هل هنالك
توافق وما هو شكل الاتفاق الذي جرى في
داخل هذا الاجتماع لكن من الواضح بان
تاخير بنيامين نتنياهو لخطابه الذي كان
منتظر في حدود الساعه العاشره والنصف هذا
يعني بان هنالك خلاف خلاف حقيقي وسجال
حقيقي حول ما ربما يعلنه بنيامين الموقف
حول وقف التشريعات القضائيه والتغييرات
القضائيه في قادم السعد
اذا نحن نتابع هذه التطورات هنا من امام
مبنى الكنيست وكما اشرت بان الشرطه
الاسرائيليه وضعت قواتها هنا على اهبه
الاستعداد القصوى هنالك العديد من الحلقات
الامنيه التي فرضتها حول مبنى الكنيست
اقامت متاريس في عده حلقات من اجل ان يصعب
هذا الامر على المتظاهرين فيما اذا قرروا
اختراق الحواجز والدخول الى مبنى الكنيست
الاسرائيلي رغم ان النيه لا تبدو على
الاقل حتى هذه الساعه انها تتجه الى هذا
الاتجاه تبدو يبدو المتظاهرون لانهم
ملتزمون بالقانون وملتزمون بالتعليمات وهم
موجودون خلف متاريس الشرطه الاسرائيليه
ولا يحاولون او على الاقل نحن لا نلاحظ
ايه محاوله حتى هذه الساعه من جانبهم
لاقتحام هذه المتاريس اعتقد بانهم هم على
قناه الان بانهم احرزوا بهذه التظاهرات
الكبيره انجازا كبيرا وعظيما من وجهه
نظرهم في محاوله ليل ذراع الحكومه
في تاريخ اسرائيل وهم يعتقدون يعني ربما
هم ليسوا بحاجه الى اقتحام هذه المدارس
لان هذه المظاهرات لم تتوقف عند كونها
مجرد حشود في الشارع ولكن انعكست على ربما
حل شركه حل حركه يعني ان تشل حركه البلاد
اذا
اساهم كل من اعلنوا عن انهم سيساهمون في
هذه الاضرابات في نقابات العمال والمهن
المختلفه
بالفعل بالفعل كذلك واسرائيل في حلا في
حاله شلل تام في كافه مرافقها الاقتصاديه
والصحيه حتى المستشفيات اعلنت انضمامها
للاضراب البنوك اعلنت انضمامها للاضراب
المحال التجاريه الكبرى الشركات الكبرى في
اسرائيل اعلنت انضمامها ودعمها لدعوه رئيس
نقابه العمال العامه في اسرائيل للسدود
الانضمام الى هذا الاضراب الجامعات
الاسرائيليه انضمت منذ ليله امس الى هذا
الاضراب كل مرافق الحياه الحيويه في
اسرائيل مشلوله بالكامل كل رؤساء النقابات
العماليه في اسرائيل وهم في قبضتهم
[موسيقى]
الاقتصاد عصب الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي كلهم
كانوا اليوم ملتفين في غرفه واحده الى
جانب رئيس نقابه العمال العامه الاستدرود
وايدوا موقفه باعلان الاضراب وهذا يشكل
بطبيعه الحال ضغطا هائلا ضغطا اقتصاديا
هائلا على بنيامين او تخيل ان 73 الف
مسافر كانوا يفترض ان يسافروا في الساعات
القليله المقبله عبر مطار بن غوريون
الدولي الى وجهات عده في العالم المطار
معطل بالكامل ميناء اسدود البحري وهو اهم
الموانئ التجاريه لاسرائيل بعد ميناء حيفا
اغلق وتعطل عن الحركه بعد ان اعلت نقابه
العمال ايضا انضمامها الى الاضراب العام
والشامل
[موسيقى]
لكن رغم ذلك لا استطيع في اسرائيل
نقلا عن اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي في هذا
الخبر العاجل شكرا جزيلا لك نعم من امام
الكنيست بالتاكيد
[موسيقى]
نتنياهو شكرا لك الياس هل سيقول نتنياهو
للمتظاهرين فهمتكم ام لا
[موسيقى]